marvel studios wandavision sparked a
level of discussion that other tv shows
can only dream about
with its frequent use of foreshadowing
and curious teases about what might be
coming in the mcu the series was chock
full of lines that may be more important
than you realized
one division is marvel studios biggest
mystery story yet and there's not really
a close second to it
for weeks viewers were deliberately left
in the dark about what was actually
going on in this inexplicable sitcom
send-off
the last time we saw wanda maximoff she
was chilling with clint barton at tony
stark's funeral
reminiscing about the past and looking
forward to the future come 2021 and
she's living in tv land married to a
miraculously revived vision with zero
explanation
the series debut episode filmed before a
live studio audience plays most of its
mid-50s tv show gimmick completely
straight with vision and wanda doing
their best to hide the fact that they're
not exactly an ordinary couple
there's the occasional double entendre
line about things like how dense vision
is for marvel fans to chuckle at
but few clues as to what's actually
going on until you go back for a second
viewing
while the visions are planning their
dinner party provisions boss and his
wife they have a phone call to explain
the stakes of the evening this dinner
needs to go well vision says so wanda
assures him that it will
wanda darling vision sweetheart listen
about tonight
don't worry dear i have everything under
control
after seeing the story once this line
means way more than it did the first
time
nine minutes into the series and wanda's
already nodding at the series's real
scenario in a very literal way
don't worry darling i have everything
under control
it's unclear why wanda and vision are so
bad at making dinner in the first
episode of wandavision it kind of feels
like cooking dinner together is the one
thing we've seen them do together as a
couple
beyond beating up bad guys and other
avengers nevertheless wanda envisions
potential inability to cook a simple
meal for vision's boss propels the drama
of the sitcom story
except for all the psychic powers and
reality warping it's the kind of thing
that would have been right at home in an
episode of i love lucy
but this isn't i love lucy it's the
marvel universe a world of advanced
science and powerful magic
at one point in the episode vision's
boss seems to sense the sorcery of work
holding the world together around him
from what i've seen here tonight you can
barely keep it together
i mean look around there's all this
chaos going on in your household
little did he know how right that was
chaos was going on in way more places
than just the household
by the end of the series we know that
chaos was taking control of the whole
tank town
this is chaos magic wanda
but that makes you the scarlet
[ __ ] one of the weird things about
wandavision is how much the tone of the
early episodes clash with the wanda
maximoff marvel fans have come to know
this is a woman who was introduced as a
villainous vengeful human lab experiment
first she was an orphan and then she
lost her brother and then she
accidentally killed a lot of innocent
people
the best thing she had going for her was
a robot boyfriend and
well we all know how that turned out
between avengers age of ultron and
avengers end game wanda developed into a
vengeful woman so animated by wrath that
she almost ended the thanos threat
single-handedly
so to see her suddenly trying to fit in
at a suburban party of homemakers and
the second episode of wandavision was
puzzling to say the least one day she's
trying to rip apart an alien warlord to
save the entire universe
the next thing we know her big mission
is trying to please dottie it just
doesn't make a lot of sense
i actually don't know what i'm doing
here i'm starting to feel that way
myself
by this point in the series more than a
couple things have happened that have
served to shake up wanda
being creepily off format or out of
place in her fabricated sitcom world
even as early as the second episode her
faith in this fake reality is starting
to pray
speaking of dottie and i'm irritated
[Music]
donnie's introduced in episode 2 as a
high-maintenance local busybody who
inexplicably has it out for wanda
in the early going of wand division when
wanda just wants to fit in in westview
donnie serves as a kind of antagonist to
that goal making wanna feel like she's
less than the other residents like she
doesn't belong
from wanda's point of view this bias
might have something to do with her
mysteriously metal husband
but of course as we later learned dottie
has a perfectly natural reason for not
liking wanda
but i assure you i don't mean anyone
any harm i don't believe you
as we later learn wanda is at this exact
moment holding dottie hostage as a
prisoner in her own mind
separated from her children and
alienated from herself it's frankly evil
from dottie's perspective
it might be seven more episodes before
the people of westby were free but lines
like this one where their real feelings
break through wanda's illusion go to
show that they were fighting for their
freedom the whole time
wanda's twin children billy and tommy
are one of the few aspects of wanda's
hex world that seemed to not be totally
of her own making
while it's certainly possible that wanda
generated the two children in the same
way that she conjured up a revived
version of her husband
there are hints that the kids may have
been implanted in her world by an
unknown outside force hints like her
consistent inability to control them
with their magic
why won't you do what i want even agatha
seems to notice that the kids have an
independent streak about them
oh kids
can't control them no matter how hard
you try
most things and wanda's hacks are
subject to her influence even vision who
should really know better
but when wanda becomes spontaneously
pregnant with the twins in the second
episode she seems like she might be as
surprised as anyone else
just kind of taking this by surprise
just kind of suddenly quite suddenly
wasn't it i mean practically overnight
in the comics wanda's twins were
initially thought to have been her own
creation
but it was later revealed that their
souls were shards of the demon mephisto
who eventually came back to reclaim them
mephisto was so entwined with the
creation of billy and tommy that many
fans were convinced wandavision was
building up to his arrival
unleash hell demon spawn that didn't
happen in the series but it doesn't mean
that the story of wanda billy and tommy
is anywhere near over
by the time the curtain closes on
wandavision we still don't know where
they came from
and we don't know where they went as
billy says in the beginning of
wandavision's sixth episode
all new halloween spectacular halloween
is a magical holiday all about family
friends and the thrill of getting to be
someone else for a day
of course wanda's been taking that idea
and running with it for a good long
while by the time halloween rolls around
she's been enjoying the thrill of being
someone else every day for weeks now and
she's taken an entire town of people
along for the ride
at this point in the series wanda isn't
entirely aware of what she's doing but
she knows enough to recognize that there
are some things she doesn't want to hear
don't bring up ultron to her for one
thing it's just not a good idea
during the halloween episode wanda gets
re-acquainted with what she believes to
be her lost twin brother pietro back
from the dead after getting fatally
ventilated during the big fight against
ultron in sokovia
but their memories don't quite sync up
and wanda notices
when she comments on the discrepancies
in one of his stories pietro was quick
to shut her down
saying he probably suppressed a lot of
the trauma
that line's referring to a whole lot
more than just this halloween story
whether he knew he was doing it or not
with that comment fake pietro was
pointing out the entire nature of
fonda's hex
a way for her to suppress and hide from
the trauma of her past
there's a really weird reference in the
halloween episode that goes many layers
deep and considering all the other
little references that are threaded
throughout wandavision it's hard to see
it as unintentional
during the trick-or-treating sequence
pietro is doing his uncle pietro thing
with billy and tommy and they hatch a
plan to maximize their candy acquisition
considering all three of these boys have
superpowers it's not really fair but it
is an exciting idea or in
tommy's words kick ass yeah kick ass
i feel the need for me
kick ass to follow the show at this
point you probably need to have seen at
minimum a half dozen marvel studios
movies one of the later fox x-men movies
at least one episode of malcolm in the
middle and a completely different comic
book movie
2010's kick-ass based on the comic book
by mark miller and john ramita jr
who appeared in that movie oh just aaron
taylor johnson and evan peters who
played off each other side by side as
the characters kick-ass and ass kicker
10 years before they played pietro and
peter maximoff in the mcu in x-men
your head hurt yet okay technically evan
peters character didn't suit up to
become ass kicker until the second movie
in which his role was recast with
another actor
much in the same way that pietro gets
recast in wand division that your head
hurts now
we're not even sure what the purpose of
this reference was beyond pointing out
how weirdly these two actors careers
intertwined
also kick-ass was more than 10 years ago
that's kind of an ass-kicking thing to
realize all by itself
it's an interesting time for the marvel
cinematic universe post end game
for years fans knew that we were heading
toward a major confrontation with big
daddy thanos
at the start of phase four the
possibilities feel wide open but the
series is still definitely already
building towards something
and that something seems to involve the
scrolls outer space and probably captain
marvel
after monica and jimmy get kicked out of
the sword base camp by director hayward
monica takes him to meet with a team of
sword agents that aren't loyal to
hayward or his agenda
they're greeted by a new character named
major goodner who greets monica warmly
monica says that her mother maria would
appreciate this group of sword agents
loyalty to which goodner replies was
something a little puzzling
she's not the only one we're loyal to
captain
there's likely more going on here than
we realize we know that scrolls are
operating on earth one of them reveals
herself at the end of the series is
mid-credit scene we know that nick fury
is up to something with them and it
looks like something big
maria rambo also obviously had a
relationship with the scrolls
whether that means these agents are
loyal to the scrolls or scrolls
themselves is something this series
doesn't answer but it does feel like
something to keep an eye on
for some viewers agatha's big mic drop
line at the end of episode 8 where she
calls wanda the scarlet witch was one of
the biggest forehead slappers on the
series
an on the nose touch that evoked the
trope of the titular line guy
oh boy i'm just so tired of all these
star wars but although marvel fans have
been referring to the character of
scarlet witch since before avengers age
of ultron even came out
technically she's never been referred to
by that name ever
the closest we ever got was tony stark
calling her a witch which was kind of
just tony being tony
that little witch is messing with your
mind this fact got some
attention in one division in episode 5
when sword director hayward is brilliant
agent jimmy wu about wanda's history
does maximov have an alias no sir
no funny nickname not a one as wu
emphasizes wanda never gave herself a
silly superhero name that's also kind of
just a tony stark thing
some wanda vision fans were surprised to
see agatha harkness dealt with by the
end of wondervision or that she was a
villain who needed defeating it all
in the comics that she comes from agatha
has always been more of an unorthodox
mentor to the heroes
sometimes an antagonist but not really a
full-on villain
that's not the case in wandavision she
killed sparky for pete's sake
but it is intriguing that agatha spends
her last moments with wanda referring to
the threats that she believes are coming
you have no idea what you've unleashed
[Music]
you're gonna need me if i do
i know where to find you wait
considering all the hints that something
greater may be out there on the mcu's
horizon we wouldn't be surprised if
wanda ends up making a trip back to west
view to get some help from agatha
could she end up becoming a loki style
frenemy in the future
only time will tell check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one